IT IS TIME TO PLAY THE SYMPTOMS.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Chris: THAT WAS OUR WHOLE
GRAPHICS BUDGET FOR THE YEAR.
IT WAS WORTH IT, THOUGH.
WHEN AMERICANS GET SICK, THEY
DON'T GO TO THE DOCTOR, THEY
GOOGLE THEIR SYMPTOMS TO SEE IF
THEY REALLY NEED TO GO TO THE
DOCTOR.
OR MAYBE THEY WILL JUST WAIT IT
OUT AND SEE IF THEY FEEL BETTER
OR DIE.
WHETHER YOU HAVE GOT HYSTERICAL
BLINDNESS OR RESTLESS RECTUM,
GOOGLE WILL TELL YOU ALL ABOUT
IT WITH DEEPLY UNSETTLING PASTEL
ILLUSTRATIONS.
COMEDIANS I WILL SHOW YOU A
GOOGLE ILLUSTRATION OF SOME
SICK-SICKIES AND FOR 250 POINTS
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO TELL ME WHAT
THEY HAVE.
ALL RIGHT.
FIRST UP, WHAT IS WRONG WITH
THIS GUY? WHAT DOES HE HAVE
THERE? OH, NO.
>> YES, DAVE FOLEY.
>> MOSQUITO SEX REGRET.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Chris: OH.
WHY DID I LET THAT MOSQUITO
FINISH INSIDE OF ME?
>> WHAT IS HAPPENING THERE?
WITH THAT -- HUMANOID CREATURE.
SUZY.
>> SHE WORE A PAIR OF TOM'S
SHOES FOR NEARLY AN HOUR.
>> Chris: YES.
POINTS.
NEXT ONE.
VERY COMMON, WHATEVER THIS IS,
MORE THAN 3 MILLION U.S. CASES
PER YEAR.
WHAT IS THAT? DAVE FOLEY.
>> MENOPAUSAL TEDIUM.
>> Chris: SIDE EFFECTS MAY
INCLUDE LONELY PICNICS.
>> POINTS TO DAVE.
NEXT ONE, THIS IS A VERY
CONFUSING SCENARIO.
WHAT IS THIS? WHAT IS THAT?
KEN.
>> ANGRY MUTANT SPERM.
>> Chris: YES.
DEFINITELY. DEFINITELY.
YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT, IT
DOES SPREAD BY SEXUAL CONTACT.
RIGHT THERE.
KEN, YOU ARE A DOCTOR, I MEAN
YOU MUST HAVE SEEN THIS BEFORE
IN YOUR PRACTICE.
>> SURE.
YEAH.
>> Chris: SUZY.
>> ARE THOSE URINALS IN THE
BACK?
>> Chris: OH, I BELIEVE THEY
ARE.
>> HE HAS DEVILED EGG DICK.
NEXT ONE, YES.
OH.
DAVE FOLEY.
>> ANKLE GENDER DYSPHORIA.
>> KEN.
>> VIN DISEASE-EL.
>> Chris: YES.
VERY WELL PLAYED.
I AM GROOT.
AND FINALLY--
THIS LADY, WHAT IS -- OH.
ERR.
GRR.
YES, KEN.
>> TELEPATHIC LINK TO HELEN IN
HUMAN RESOURCES.
>> Chris: YES.
POINTS.
(BLEEP)ING HELEN, EVERY TIME.
>> (BLEEP)ING HELEN.
>> Chris: SUZY.
>> SHE CAN'T REMEMBER IF SHE
LEFT HER BABY IN THE CAR.
>> Chris: POINTS.
OH.
DAVE FOLEY.
>> FOREHEAD (BLEEP).
IT IS A HAPPY PICTURE.
IT IS A VERY HAPPY PICTURE.
>> TREATED BY A MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL AND THE DOCTOR
IS IN.
>> AND OUT AND IN.
AND IN.